ah
[Música]
bueno los huevos ancestrales para mí
significa resaltar la cultura y el
deporte de cada pueblo la cual está
integrado por los siete pueblos
originarios de panamá aquí venimos a
demostrar que la mujer también tiene
fuerza y tiene derecho de igualdad ya de
que hay fuerza y voluntad en las
comarcas
[Música]
y allá se hace naturalmente todos los
días de fuerza como rajar leña pescar lo
que es el barón es casi igual parecido a
lo que hace la mujer
[Música]
y yo fui la única que le pegó esto la
gran mayoría la compañeros que no
tuvieron autoridad no le pegaron no le
aceptaron pero hoy por hoy no
necesitamos lar que la flecha para
alimentarnos pero sí de manera deportiva
para recrearnos
[Música]